il y a 20 ans on parlait des produits du
terroir aujourd'hui on parle davantage
d'achat local est-ce que c'est la même
chose et est-ce qu'il reste du travail à
faire pour leur mise en valeur vos
sommes du terroir québécois on était
chercher un mot ça va qu'est-ce que
c'est une recette du terroir québécois
faudrait peut-être le définir des
protéines de soya mais en tout cas ma
grand-mère on ne mettait pas de dessous
dans son ragoût de boulettes en 2004
l'épicerie faisait un premier reportage
sur les produits
issus du terroir québécois et le constat
n'était pas très positif pour cette chef
qui a toujours travaillé pour la
reconnaissance et la mise en valeur de
nos richesses alimentaires c'est beau ou
soit de dire que ça vient de telles
fermes que c'est vrai mais qui me prouve
ça et qu'est-ce que c'est à part juste
de vouloir y croire
les tomates si ben on peut dire c'est
local on est où 20 ans plus tard mais je
dirais pas qu'on est arrivé mais on y
est presque on a fait un grand bout de
chemin vraiment là pour moi
au début des années 80 fin 70 j'essaie
de trouver des produits locaux et c'est
très très difficile en dehors des
fraises au mois de juin puis des petits
fruits de quelques produits c'est
vraiment là c'est comme toutes les
importations mais à partir des années
2000 là ça s'est mis vraiment à bouger
c'est à cette époque que le marché des
saveurs voit le jour ce commerce dont
l'émission a toujours été de rendre
accessible les produits régionaux
l'essence du projet initial c'était
justement ça c'était de prendre les
produits qui étaient disponibles en
région les concentrés dans un même lieu
pour pouvoir les présenter à clientèle
localise les produits régionaux
existaient déjà mais il fallait faire
beaucoup de kilomètres pour
s'approvisionner
et petit à petit les grands joueurs ont
suivi le pas maintenant quand on
s'aperçoit que même les grandes
distributeurs alimentaires font de plus
en plus de place assez transformateurs
là c'est pas du temps régionaux de
victoire
malima Québec ont aussi fait beaucoup
beaucoup ça a eu un succès les gens ont
adoré ça le mot terroir on l'entendait
beaucoup aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup
de l'achat local est-ce que c'est la
même chose le mot terroir quel terroir
pour moi c'est un peu galvaudé on se
comprend qu'un terroir c'est limité
aussi par un territoire un type de sol
un climat il y a beaucoup de choses là
que ça implique l'achat local c'est tout
le côté vert écologique là on est plus
dans une dynamique économisée les
énergies fossiles alors je t'achète plus
locale il y a moins de transport alors
produit local ou produit du terroir on
veut juste clarifier la situation un
Desjardins posaient déjà la question en
2004 dans un rapport sur les
appellations réservées et les produits
du terroir on demande au gouvernement
d'être plus spécifique quand on dit
quelque chose il faudrait que ça soit
défini le mot terroir ou le mot
artisanal
ou Fermi qu'est-ce que c'est que ça veut
dire
le rapport au départ ça fait un peu de
vagues ça fait de bouger les choses
premièrement il a éclairé beaucoup sur
je dirais les problématiques que l'autre
chose que ça a fait aussi c'est que en
en parlant beaucoup de chefs italiens
sont devenus comme plus
avertis sur le sujet sur la question et
ça c'est ça qui fait bouger le
gouvernement aussi bouge évoque une
nouvelle loi en 2006 dans le but de
protéger l'authenticité des produits et
de désignation qui les mettent en valeur
le terme terroir n'apparaît qu'une seule
fois dans la loi en tant que catégorie
d'appellation des appellations
aujourd'hui ou nombre de 8 quelles sont
elles sont tellement de Neuville
l'agneau de Charlevoix les vins de
glaces qui va du Québec les sites du
Québec fromage la race de vache
canadiennes le tout nouveau où est le
fromage fermier exactement agronome de
formation Marie-Josée Gouin et la
président directrice générale du quarté
V le Conseil des appellations réservées
et des termes valorisants l'organisme
gouvernemental qui encadre les
appellations du Québec
pourquoi on a besoin de certifier un
produit pour qu'il soit social au
terroir mais c'est une reconnaissance
c'est une reconnaissance à long terme
une pérennité du produit pérennité du
savoir-faire ça nous permet de cultiver
notre patrimoine notre territoire le
vignoble saint Thomas dans la noudière
produit des vins qui bénéficient de
l'appellation
IGP vin du Québec la certification ça
sert vraiment à avoir une reconnaissance
puis il y a un panel de dégustateurs qui
goûte tes vins puis approuvent dire bon
ok c'est des bons vins du Québec et puis
il y a un logo donc on peut aller
chercher les consommateurs de plus qui
connaissent ce logo là
au-delà des appellations il est possible
de protéger un produit grâce à des
certifications n'importe qui qui veut
faire une demande d'accréditation
suivant un cahier de charges il peut le
faire mais tout ça ça coûte de l'argent
c'est compliqué
c'est la raison pour laquelle le meunier
allait valoir est allé chercher une
certification privée moins contraignante
mais non reconnue par le quart TV son
moulin peut donc produire aujourd'hui
des farines provenant de 8 fermes de la
Mauricie la certification en gris nature
fait qu'on est capable d'embarquer
quelques producteurs qui vont utiliser
pas de pesticides dans certains champs
une année en cours donc ça vient aider à
réduire la pression des pesticides dans
l'environnement puis aussi améliorer la
santé des gens donc on parle la machine
mon but c'était de valorisé des récoltes
de producteurs pour offrir aux
consommateurs un produit vraiment local
ça c'est beau ça même si parfois c'est
pas toujours des appellations il y a de
plus en plus de petites fermes de
producteurs qui font de très belles
choses
des outils de protection pour les
producteurs mais le consommateur lui
est-il gagnant dans tout cela ça peut
rassurer les clients pour dire ok il y a
quelque chose d'une certification donc
on va commencer par ces vins là on l'a
vu
emballé au Québec contacté au Québec
transformé au Québec produit du Québec
mais c'est là qu'on a un rôle à jouer au
niveau du conseil de faire connaître des
appellations un consommateur qui en 20
ans est devenu de plus en plus averti
beaucoup plus d'informations il y a
beaucoup plus curieux ces questions sont
beaucoup plus précises il veut savoir
d'où ça vient c'est fait comme on parle
de développement durable on parle
directement à la ferme de la ferme à la
table la traçabilité du produit donc oui
le consommateur a fait de grands pas on
voyait les bébés boomers qui arrivaient
ici je faisais toujours habitué de
prendre une bouteille de France
puisqu'elle faisait une folie prenait la
bouteille d'à côté maintenant c'est
différent les gens veulent goûter à
plein de sortes de choses puis surtout
le la clientèle est de plus en plus
jeune je vous dirais que les jeunes
consommateurs sont très informés
sont très informés des fois ils sont
tellement informés qui cherchent quelque
chose de très très spécifique beaucoup
de travail a donc été fait au cours des
20 dernières années pour valoriser nos
produits d'ici alors que reste-t-il à
faire acheter ces voté mais acheter
c'est aussi décider où on achète puis
comment on achète juste un pouvoir qu'on
garde il faut le terroir du Québec là
qui rayonne beaucoup plus large puis si
on rayonne beaucoup plus large mais on
va amener plus d'eau moulin puis les
producteurs vont vouloir adhérer puis
économiquement ça va aller mieux
[Musique]